[Musique]
il ya très longtemps c'est touchant des
nao faire un miracle à notre famille sa
magie à donner vie à notre maison notre
cas ci au lac a cité
[Musique]
le temps venu chaque membre de notre
famille
reçoit son propre 12 magie
oui je comprends je suis pas une force
de la nature comme muse les mulets sont
encore dehors
ni naturellement parfaite comme señorita
pulp et à isabelle
une mama pourquoi suis-je la seule à
n'avoir aucun dos tu es aussi
exceptionnel que n'importe quel membre
de cette famille
tu viens de guérir maman avec ounaré pa
kong et tha
site
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il
la magie est en danger devons partir
nous devons protéger notre maison
protéger notre famille
c'est ma seule chance juste sauverait la
machine attendez vous comment sauve la
magie
mirabel l'avenir de la famille dépend
entièrement de droit
j'y arriverai jamais
les rames ont dit tous les secrets ne
les mangent pas
dans les pierres mandat
la lumière revient
quand on s'y attend le
[Musique]
oh
tout s'est mal mais ce qui compte c'est
que j'ai un ami enfin j'ai cru que
j'avais un ami la soeur